[Music]
thank you
a very good morning to you the top
stories from Sky News live here in the
city of London house price growth slips
back in May as new research suggests
arranging a mortgage is becoming harder
for many people
a crunch deal to raise the U.S debt
ceiling passes through the House of
Representatives
Amazon agrees to pay millions to settle
two privacy cases against its Alexa and
ring doorbells plus sailing sustainably
the world's first Net Zero Journey for a
cruise ship
foreign
[Music]
very good morning to you to Ian King
live with me Wilfred Frost filling in
for Ian this week and now of course of
business and economic news from the city
of London house prices fell at their
fastest annual rate since July 2009
according to Nationwide the building
society says prices in the year to May
were down by 3.4 percent it comes as
hundreds of mortgage deals have been
taken off the market in the last week
joining me now to discuss sir this is uh
Andrew Harvey nationwide's uh senior
Economist Andrew thanks so much for for
joining us this morning
um so so clearly we had seen a little
bit of a bounce in in house prices in
April May has now reignited the trend of
the last six to eight months one of one
of falling house prices uh is that fair
does it look like that is the trend
downwards and and that April was the
aberration as as opposed to to May
falling back down being the aberration
well I think what we certainly have been
seeing is a little bit of um sort of
volatility in terms of the recovery
perhaps recovery altering just a little
bit at the moment everything about may
actually prices were pretty much flat
um and if we compare to where we were a
year ago as you mentioned we're down 3.4
but that's on a very strong base in
terms of house prices were still running
at Double Digit Pace
um last year so I think it's more of a
picture of a some someone a bumpy
recovery it's certainly true headwinds
uh at the moment
um are growing and certainly in terms of
what we've been seeing with mortgage
rates and actually more recently the
kinds of activity impact so a bit of a
faltering in the recovery activity as
well and today's Bank of England numbers
for example showed a surprise ball in
house purchases approvals and they're in
about 25 year on year and also about 25
down compared to where we would have
been pre-pandemic so a relatively
subdued picture at the moment in terms
of housing market activities
but I'm really interested that based on
what you're saying there it seems to me
your base case is that the recovery has
started that the worst of any house
price correction is is in the past
well we we are expecting um a pizza
truffle for around six percent house
prices are now down around four percent
compared to their August feat so yes in
that sense we have actually seen quite a
lot of the Fall we would expect to come
through I think what we're seeing
perhaps more recently is perhaps
challenging that a little bit in terms
of perhaps the conditions are not
improving quite as quickly as we might
have hoped the signs um earlier in this
year are a little bit more encouraging
in terms of where mortgage applications
were going I think um what we're seeing
at the moment certainly in the short
term is a little bit more turbulence a
lot that is associated with the rise in
mortgage rates we've just seen over the
last week or so
um a a peak to drop fall of six percent
seems incredibly optimistic to me I mean
what what uh is your sort of forecast
for rates from here over the next 12
months for that that to play out are you
expecting mortgage rates to to come back
down significantly in order to support
that or you think house prices won't
fall more Peak to trough than six
percent if if mortgage rates stay where
they are four five six percent for the
next year or so
I think our thinking over really over
the median term is that we will see some
improvement in mortgage rates we've got
a bit of a bump in the road I suppose
um at the moment that the labor market
conditions are still um very strong and
very supportive and unemployment remains
low
um nominal um income growth is also
quite strong and coupled with some
modest forms of house prices over this
year we think the housing affordability
conditions will improve over time but
that is conditioned on mortgage rates
and starting to improve later in the
year which we think will happen once
Bank rates Peak we do think the market
expectations will start to come down but
that is very the important factor there
is that inflation does continue to slow
and that's the thing which has surprised
the market more recently and so we'll be
hoping for more positive news later in
the year in terms of a slowing in the
rate of inflation
um we're expecting bank rate probably to
increase slightly from here perhaps
towards five percent but we think that
will be the peak
and and uh clearly during the pandemic
and immediately afterwards there was
quite a bifurcation between urban
suburban and and Rural properties is
that now passed is everything a bit more
uniform again or or are there still
those uh those uh bifurcations
I think a lot of those factors seem to
have fallen away a bit now in terms of
importance and what people are looking
for and patterns of return a little bit
more more to usual um but I think
certain things like for example rail
links into major cities are still
proving quite important especially for
those perhaps who work more hybrid work
and pattern we need to go into the city
a couple of times a week so we're
starting to see the perhaps look the
meter hot spots and the uh the music
belt starting to come back a bit
certainly in terms of what we've seen in
property types it's still tending to be
sort of the larger property types which
are proving more attractive allowing
people extra space working of a home
where they where they can afford to do
so and it's tended to be smaller
property types especially Flats which
have underperformed really over the last
couple of years
Andrew Harvey thanks so much for joining
us thank you thank you
now the US is a big step closer to
avoiding a potentially disastrous
default on its debts uh bill which
allows the government to borrow more
money has passed the House of
Representatives and now Force faces an
easier path through the Senate before
then landing on President Joe Biden's
desk he's urged Senators to get it to
him quickly our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone has the latest for us from
Washington
well American politics has a strange
ability to create a sort of manufactured
Jeopardy if you really believe that the
country's politicians would actually
allow the nation to default for the
first time in its history but this game
of chicken really has gone to the wire
both sides have been unwilling to move
even to negotiate until the very last
moment so that they could eke out
concessions and to be clear it is a game
which could go wrong and if a default
did happen well there would be a genuine
global economic crisis the vote
overnight in there for the deal to raise
the debt ceiling means that the crisis
is closer to being avoided congressmen
and women found consensus to vote for
the deal which had been hammered out by
President Biden and his political foe
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy it passed
by 314 to 117. there were concessions on
both sides no one was happy it was clear
in their pre-votes speeches that so many
politicians have deep deep reservations
about the level of unsustainable debt
that this country is having to take on
the bill will now head to Senators they
will probably want to make amendments
but they are very likely to pass it the
crisis will then be averted this game of
chicken over the debt ceiling raised the
can though simply kicked down the road
my son there uh worth noting That Wall
Street did close lower yesterday of
course that deal in Congress came after
the close but you saw the S P 500 down
0.6 and just interesting to note that
even though that deal has come since
that close uh overnight that the U.S
pre-market is only up slightly the s p
Futures up about a quarter of one
percent highlighting that the market had
largely expected this debt deal uh to be
extended uh as tense as uh it was uh
certainly would have been a much bigger
fall had it failed than there was a
bounce uh given that it succeeded one
more step to come of course uh in the
Senate as Mark highlighted right some
other stories now uh Amazon will pay
more than 24 million pounds to settle
alleged to privacy violations involving
its Voice Assistant Alexa and ring
doorbell camera us Regulators accused
Amazon among other things of mishandling
data gathered by the devices in response
Amazon told Sky News we take our
responsibilities to our customers and
their families very seriously adding our
device and services are built to protect
customers privacy and to provide
customers with control over their
experience while we disagree with the
ftc's claims regarding both Alexa and
ring and deny violating the law these
settlements put these matters behind us
Dr Martens has reported a drop in
pre-tax profits down 26 percent to 159
million pounds for the year up to the
end of March the northampton-based
Footwear maker has faced a number of
marketing and distribution issues in the
U.S and has warned the profit margins
will fall this year but the company did
see annual revenues hit a billion pounds
for the first time
the car market continues to suffer from
Supply difficulties according to auto
trader this morning the company posted
its full year results with an adjusted
operating profit of 322 million pounds
up 10 on the previous year I've been
speaking to auto traders chief executive
Nathan Coe and I asked him if a huge
price surge of cars has tempered at all
or are they still trading at very good
values in any long-term historical
comparison
if they were diamonds last year they
still are this year I wouldn't say that
they've kind of appreciated beyond that
we haven't seen them come down I mean
actually in the last couple of months
prices are ticking forward a little bit
from those already high values so
um it all comes down to a balance
between supply and demand and Supply is
still pretty tight we're not really
seeing new car volumes come through
strongly which means you're not getting
the used cars coming through and demand
remains very very high and I think it is
understandable because if you look at
the period kind of post or from covert
to now there are probably five million
transactions that in normal times we
would have expected to happen across the
new and used car markets they haven't
and at some point you've got to imagine
that a lot of those will catch up so I
imagine this might stay the case for a
lot longer than people might be
ordinarily expecting well that's
interesting because clearly it's fed
through to decent results for you guys
once again talk us through that but then
but then your forecast for the year
ahead so you think this can continue for
the foreseeable future
yeah I mean I think you probably summed
it up there so our results
um retailers are doing well we've got
lots of consumers turning to auto trader
to buy their next car we've got this
thing called electric vehicles which is
throwing a bit of confusion into the mix
and getting people to do even more
research online and those two things
together right up to
um pretty good results for us combined
with some good execution by all our
teams so if you look at the core Auto
Trader business the website platform
apps that you would know that business
grew nine percent
um on a revenue basis and 10 on an
operating
profit basis and then we did an
acquisition last year so if you add it
all up and look look at it together
um revenues are actually up 16 and are
on an adjusted basis
um just to remove some kind of one-off
charges relating to Acquisitions
earnings per showers up um six percent
so pretty solid results
um and ahead of where people were
generally in line with what people were
expecting and I think in terms of the
year ahead a lot of those dynamic mix we
see as you rightly say remaining pretty
similar actually we expect consumers to
still retain lots of interesting cars we
expect retailers to still be doing
pretty well and we'd expect that to to
flow through as well so it is more or
less a bit more of the same for the next
next year as well which is ahead of what
people expected and and I mean clearly
you mentioned there that the supply
constrained and people are holding on to
their cars as things start is that
simply because of a desire to hold on to
a car that people have bought or is it
stemming from the fact that the new car
market itself is Supply constrained no a
great question and I think it's more the
latter than it is the former I think
people have been forced to hold on to
their cars for one of two reasons one
because they want a new car and you know
a lot of people will there is a big
portion of the market well not massive
portion of Map There's a good portion of
the market that will just get their car
on a three-year PCP they'll buy it new
at the end of it they give it back to
the retailer they swap it for a new one
well you've just not really been able to
do that or you've been told there's a
12-month wait on the particular new car
that you're looking for so you're forced
into holding it you know for up to a
year longer than you would normally do
and if you're holding on to it for a
year then you're not part exchanging
that car and those people that would
ordinarily look for a one or two year
old car well they can't buy a car either
and they've had to hold on to it so it
kind of ripples it ripples down it's
really a supply thing um what changes
isn't so much the supply if there is a
bit less demand or if people are looking
to hold on their cards for longer then
it'll start to feed through in weaker
use car prices so that that that that's
why your first question I thought was
very good because it does balance all
things out basically and tell you how it
how it's going and and in terms of
what's holding its value best relative
to their initial new price I mean
clearly there was a a huge interest in
EVS that has been steadily growing over
the last decade but this constrained
Supply does it oddly in fact mean that
combustion engine cars are having a bit
of a Renaissance
um yeah yeah I mean you're definitely on
it in terms of your forecast at the
moment petrol vehicles are doing very
very well and Diesel uh are not doing as
well as petrol but they're not doing
badly at all there's definitely a cloud
that's hanging over diesel that isn't
the same
um Cloud that hangs over petrol and
interestingly though both those Vehicles
if you look two or three months ago
we're doing better than electric now
that will surprise you because you
imagine well everyone wants an electric
vehicle they're really expensive there's
a lot of demand well interestingly in
the last kind of six months you've
started to see the wave of electric
vehicle production that's come through
in the last few years hit the used car
market actually whilst demand was high
Supply kind of rocketed past it and
there was a little bit of weakness in
electric vehicle prices which we've now
now seen stabilized so you are
definitely I mean you are seeing strong
demand across the board for all cars it
tends to be about supply and demand and
actually for a petrol vehicle that
supplies a bit tighter and the demand's
still solid so you are seeing you know
strong pricing
um in those vehicles
foreign
let's have a look now at the market
picture and start with the Asia
overnight up but not too significantly
the Nicki as you can see is up nearly a
percent uh sort of mixed picture for the
rest of the bag but it comes after uh
sharp declines uh for the month of May
for most of Asia Korea was higher but a
lot of China rated stocks were down a
lot and they were down yesterday so a
little bit of a tepid bounce today in
Europe something similar as well because
you did see negative performance for May
more in the tune of about four percent
for the ftse 100 and starting the month
of June well in fact improving quite
significantly over the last hour
um I wasn't expected to see that up now
nearly uh 1.2 percent for uh Germany and
nearly two percent for uh Italy 4100 uh
for you where we uh seeing similar
similar pictures slightly improving
through the morning uh up about half of
one percent for the footsie if we look
at currencies uh the pound uh not moving
too much despite that U.S debt deal in
fact the dollar kind of gained a little
bit earlier in the week as opposed to as
the deal passed last night in the House
of Representatives as you can see in
fact the pound is flat against the
dollar at 124. oil prices which also
declined sharply during the month of May
down eight or nine percent depending
whether you look at Brent or WTI
bouncing a little bit today up a third
of one percent for Brent trading just
shy of 73 bucks per barrel
uh let's discuss markets uh and the
economy and a stupenitzker global macro
Economist at Fidelity yeah joins me Anna
very good to see you thanks so much for
joining us why don't we start on that
deal last night uh which uh obviously
passed the House of Representatives the
U.S debt deal still got to pass the
Senate still got to get signed by the
president but but does that alter your
outlook for US GDP much or is it just a
sort of relief that it's a risk that's
passed could it's a relief it's some
really for Mark even though Market s
were not too worried about it if you
look at market pricing they were a bit
of war in certain segments of the market
but overall there wasn't too much priced
in but it's it's a relief in terms of
the tail risk being priced out and that
really bad scenario is not materializing
in terms of the GDP implications when we
look at the estimates of what this
spending cards might mean for GDP it's
often out of 0.2 percent so it's really
marginal and actually much much lower
um relative to 0.7 what we saw in 2011
after the last debt ceiling
um debacle and now we can we can relax
we don't have to think about it
hopefully if everything passes through
this week until later next year until
after elections and so whilst we're
talking about the US there's been quite
a lot of data as ever over the last
couple of weeks but but it's really
pointing in different directions now
depending on which part of the economy
you're looking at putting the FED in an
Ever tighter but bind because it does
still have this ongoing inflation issue
whereas other parts of the economy
Chicago PMI yesterday are dropping what
is your latest expectation on where the
FED goes from here do they squeeze in
one more 25 basis point hike I think
they have tried to adjust their
communication recently saying that June
they might take a pause but then they
might still continue hiking and it's a
very difficult environment for them
because they focus on the indicators
that are lagging that is inflation and
the labor market then employment rate
rather than leading so leading
indicators are showing that the economy
is slowing and that's tightening that's
already in the system is hitting the
credit Channel credit standards are very
tight and there are lags but it's lead
it's it's hitting the real economy
already and so uh the economy is slowing
but when you look at lagging indicators
like unemployment and inflation is still
pretty high so in terms of the
expectations we think they might
actually have to hike more indeed after
after the pause in June and in terms of
uh here in Europe are we seeing quite a
difference now in the prospect for what
central banks are going to do
Continental Europe ECB versus Bank of
England yeah I think the key is really
um in inflation expectations in Europe
they are stable and pretty well anchored
and in fact the latest set of data
showed that the European inflation is
slowing not just on the headline but on
core and the ECB is pretty lucky I think
in this respect they can start thinking
about ending the cycle so perhaps one or
two hikes from them and then they are
done and they can be patient and to
watch what happens to the economy here
in the UK for the Boe the situation is
much trickier because you do have the
economy slowing in in terms of in
various parts but inflation is high and
inflation expectations are showing some
signs of the anchoring and this is a
very dangerous situation for a central
bank to be so they actually might have
to hike more than they want and then
touch on us sir Anna if you can on on
the outlook for China from here I mean
clearly U.S tech stocks have continued
to perform but everyone performed in the
very early part of this year in large
part on on hopes for China's GDP
exploding this year is that is that now
a only very distant hope
China recovery is still quite fragile
it's very nuanced and it's an even
and now we have seen already the benefit
of reopening and so now a lot depends on
the policy action if there's significant
weakness in Services which we're not
seeing yet it's mainly in manufacturing
but when we see significant weakness in
Services then the government is expected
to potentially ease policy both monetary
and fiscal I think a lot depends on
stimulus from here but we're not expect
expecting a really huge rebound what we
call it a kind of a model through
recovery in coming months and thanks so
much for joining us thank you much
appreciate it I'm just going to Pivot
away from the business news for some
breaking news concerning the deaths in
Bournemouth uh yesterday that we've been
bringing to you here on Sky News we've
got a statement from Dorset police uh
which reads quote we continue to
investigate these circumstances
surrounding the tragic incident that
occurred yesterday resulting in the
deaths of a 12 year old girl and 17 year
old boy we are working with partner
agencies to understand what has caused
the tragedy however early investigation
indicates that there was no physical
contact between a vessel and any
Swimmers at the time of the incident we
are investigating these circumstances
that cause a number of swimmers to get
into difficulty further information will
be released as the investigation
progresses and we will have more of
course on that story here on Sky News
throughout the day
still to come here on Ian King live
while getting a mortgage is more
difficult than arranging a wedding as
things stand we'll be right back
[Music]
after a lifetime in the spotlight we all
know Harry's feelings on the Press
Prince Harry to give evidence Harry's
hatred of the British tabloid press is
well documented they claimants say that
those at the very top knew about phone
hacking that'll be the first time since
the 19th century the senior Royal has
been called to the witness box
full coverage on Sky News
thank you
I'm Becky Johnston a Sky News
correspondent part of the teams based
here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
getting more and more stabbings and
essentially I think it's more and more
younger children as a team we're not
really surprised by anything these days
so it's reports of a male he's been
standing repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools but better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter before
it starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
welcome back uh well yesterday we
reported here on Ian King live that
hundreds of mortgage deals have been
taken off the market in the last week
and today a new report by lendinvest
suggests that people are finding it
harder than ever to get a mortgage well
joining me now is uh Rod Lockhart the
chief executive of lend uh invest and uh
firstly just quickly break down for us
Rod what you guys do that's that's
slightly different to traditional
mortgage brokers so we're a fintech
mortgage provider that means that we've
built and used technology to make the
process of getting a mortgage more
straightforward so with other lenders
you might have to fill in tons of paper
forms sign uh sign loads of documents
get documents certified PDFs of bank
statements flying backwards and forwards
with us that process has been completely
digitized so it's a simple
straightforward faster more transparent
process and and in terms of how that can
help the the consumers are there some
areas that traditional lenders sort of
rule people out and and absolutely right
so one of the Rangers mortgage ranges we
focus on is providing mortgages to
self-employed people contract workers
key workers people with multiple sources
of income and the technology that we've
built allows us to piece together that
income build an understanding of their
income profile of these borrowers and
and provide them with mortgages really
really interesting and so let's talk
about the broad picture for mortgages at
the moment and I mean I guess we just
mentioned in the intro clearly rates are
are ticking up yeah um to what extent
was that to be expected uh almost the
anomaly was that they came down a bit in
the early part of the Year versus uh
taking Everyone by surprise in the
industry yeah look I think that's a fair
point base rates up at four and a half
percent
um out for example our cheapest
five-year fixed rate mortgage is
currently 5.29 which in that context
doesn't seem uh doesn't seem
unreasonable
um but I think um clearly um consumers
Brokers have got used to mortgages being
at a low rate for a long period of time
and this adjustment to this new higher
interest rate environment is taking time
there was a bit of a shock last week so
when the inflation number came out
um clearly markets responded there's an
expectation that interest rates will now
continue to rise beyond beyond four and
a half percent you know potentially to
five and a half percent
um later later this year and and and
that has had some effect on the mortgage
input costs so as a result mortgage
lenders have have repriced their
mortgage ranges and many of them are
continuing to do so clearly most people
have their mortgage fixed to some extent
probably not for the life of the
mortgage but at least initially so we
all debate you know where is the current
three or five year fixed is it four
percent five percent five point two nine
you just mentioned is that the key
factor or is what's more important for
for consumers and I guess by implication
for house prices how long we stay up
anywhere near that level and and to what
extent the longer we stay here will we
suddenly see waves more people uh
finding trouble and coming out to house
prices well I think part of the the
adjustment that we've seen in mortgage
prices over over recent days is a
recognition that higher interest rates
are around and likely to be around for a
bit longer so I think that's sort of
factored into the mortgage pricing
um Banks building societies not non-bank
lenders when they're looking at pricing
mortgages they're looking at interest
rate swaps and so expectations of what's
happening to interest rates over the the
periods of time in which the mortgage
rates are fixed and and it's that that
part of the market that's moved and um
giving an indication that the higher
interest rates are going to be here for
a while uh in terms of where the uh
gentleman from uh Nationwide on earlier
who said house prices from Peak to
trough so far down four percent and
their forecast Peak to trough was down
six percent I mean does that seem
optimistic to you or does that tally
with what you're saying it that's that
sort of tallies with what we're seeing
so I think some of the heat that came
into the market during covid has come
out with the the recent fools
um for what it's worth our expectation
of Peter trough fall is around 10
um but you know to put that in some
context that's just some of the house
price rise that we've experienced uh
immediately post covered with with that
housing boom great stuff Rod thanks so
much for joining us thanks a lot good to
see you
if I still come here on uh Ian kingly
live the world's most sustainable cruise
ship prepares to set sail we'll talk to
the executive chairman
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back as the travel sector
continues to recover post lockdown
Cruises have seen a rebound over the
course of the last 18 months but the
industry is facing growing scrutiny over
its sustainability MSC cruises the
world's third largest cruise company is
launching what it claims is the world's
most environmentally efficient cruise
ship the MSC uribia which is powered by
liquefied natural gas will set off on
its maiden voyage from France to
Copenhagen this weekend and I'm joined
Now by Pierre Francesco Vargo executive
chairman of MSC cruises a very good
morning to you thanks so much for for
joining us so I I guess as you're saying
it's the most sustainable
environmentally friendly cruise ship
ever but because of the way it's powered
well good morning we're Fred good
morning everyone well obviously we we we
started with this technology LNG and and
the design of the ship started 10 years
ago so today we have a fact you know an
LNG an LNG allows us to use a synthetic
biofuels and obviously this is a huge
step ahead so we actually have in we
reached the capability to prove that in
2023 with the ship a cruise ship a large
ship we can actually have a net zero
Voyage like you were correctly saying
the vessel will the person is there this
weekend going to Copenhagen and with a
mixture of energy saving intenary
planning and and mass balance of Bio LNG
we actually proving that already in 2023
we can have a ship that has a net zero
Voyage which is which is a huge
achievement a very big achievement uh
just just on the surface of it I mean
how big a Improvement is that to the
bulk of The Fleets that are out there
across you and your Rivals are they far
from joining this ship in being Net Zero
look
you know the the point is that we we
need for shipping in general for the
maritime industry The Wider Maritime
industry we need alternative fuels uh so
we actually with LNG we've done an
incredible Step Ahead you know in
actually having this very complex piece
of Machinery uh you know that can be
propelled with such Innovative fuel
obviously if we can have a synthetic
elng if we can have a biology obviously
you know and the same can be said for
other type of fuels then obviously the
reduction the impact on the emission on
the grass Greenhouse grass
emission could be improved tremendously
um and and do you think the fact that
you will be able to as you are today
Market this as as the most sustainable
Cruise uh ever do you think that will
boost demand specifically for this uh
this this Cruise
you know
um
cruise ships Cruiser as an industry has
always been pointed fingers at lately uh
you know that we we we're not doing our
job and I think we didn't communicate
good enough in the past I think there is
a lot we should be proud of what we are
doing when we invest in these complex
pieces of Machinery we invest in excess
of a billion obviously we amortized the
ships in 30 years
more or less and when we designed them
from the time of delivery let's say in
three years time and we need to
understand not only what people would
like to eat and how they will want to be
entertained in 2030 but obviously we go
around the world and we actually put the
best technology that is available you
know for us to understand that we have a
commitment which is net zero in 2050. so
many times I say there is a lot of
Technology you know maybe up to 70
percent little things that is not like a
miraculous solution a magic wand that
will give us going that will give us the
capability to be Net Zero but between
many technical advances and obviously
with the renewable fuels with the like I
would say synthetic fuels biofuels you
know then we can achieve a data 2050.
and obviously we need to communicate
because what we're doing with some of
the ships you know the advanced water
treatment the advanced waste how we do
the recycle recycle waste we even have a
notation for the propellers that you
know they don't have the sound that
disturbs mammals underwater so we
actually noiseless underwater so we're
actually doing incredible technical
advances that actually one day they may
be utilized you know in civil society
and I'm referring for example to the
fuel cell technology and just finally
Pierre Francesco are you seeing demand
for your industry broadly back to
pre-pandemic levels
well consumer wants to travel they want
to see a sunset they want to do it from
the comfort of their balcony you know
enjoying a beer and mingling so yes a
consumer wants to go cruising the value
for money of cruising is well understood
what you you know we are very
competitive to other land-based type of
holidays ships are full so we have a
very strong and bullish 2023 which makes
us very happy because obviously through
the pandemic we've been burning cash
2022 wasn't that easy you know with all
the events and during the waves booking
season so 23 looks very strong
Pierre Francesca thanks so much for
joining us
thank you
right Japan has long been established as
a big player in the world of whiskey
producing award-winning labels that have
challenged the Scottish and Irish
Industries the Japanese whiskey
manufacturing manufacturer santori is
marking its 100th birthday and to
celebrate the acclaimed director Sophia
Coppola has directed its newest advert
with Keanu Reeves who has a history with
the brand film fans will remember that
the brand featured heavily two decades
ago in the movie Lost in Translation
well joining me now is uh John Potter
managing director at the house of
santori thanks so much for for joining
us and and uh congrats uh on the on the
the Centenary for the brand I I have to
ask actually does that put you as as a
very old manufacturer when it comes to
the world of whiskey or or no I mean I'm
serious as a brand and most brands more
Legacy than that I mean there's such a
Advent of new brands in in the in the um
in the spirit space at the moment I just
wonder where it puts you relatively
speaking
well we're probably not as old as some
of the scotch houses but we are the
pioneering House of Japanese whiskey so
we are really the first uh house from
from Japan
um so I'd say we're still at the uh the
start of our journey we've got a long
way to go and it's been a highly
successful uh 100 Years and we're
looking forward to the next hundred
years
um I I know we've got some pictures of
this uh Centenary uh celebration advert
which perhaps will play over some of the
interview but uh but but where do you
think you've got in terms of penetrating
with the Japanese products we'll come to
some of your other products uh that the
markets abroad obviously the UK US you
see them a lot lot more than as recent
as 10 years ago is it still tip of the
iceberg or have you found that you've
made decent progress on that penetration
that's still tip of the iceberg
um and you know the the lovely thing
about the house Centurion and the brands
like yamazaki and ibiki is that the
demand is is there globally uh and so
you know we're very excited by the
opportunity to build this beautiful
Brands and bring not just Japanese
whiskey to the world but Japanese
culture to the world
um and and do you purposefully maintain
quite a premium brand image and pricing
I mean the delicious but quite expensive
well that that's a reflection of demand
outstripping Supply so yes we we love
our prayers to be premium our job is to
do two things one is actually to
maintain that quality and the second one
is actually to supply more to the market
that's complex when you're looking at
brands that are 30 years old and 17 and
21 years old you've got to be thinking
long term so even addressing some of
those Supply constraints is going to
take time
in terms of uh of the broader company I
mean of course it's called beam santori
a merger with with Jim Bean some years
ago so there's quite a lot of American
whiskeys in in your
Fleet of Brands too do you feel even
though there's been growth in some
premium whiskeys do you feel like you've
missed out on some of the other I mean
gin for example's obviously exploded
over the last decade I mean do you
consider that as a as a missed
opportunity or or how do you think about
it well we think about again that the
opportunity for the house of Centauri is
to go beyond whiskey or we've actually
introduced a few years ago beautiful
gentle broken it stands for six at six
Botanicals and it's one of the fastest
growing Dunes in the world we also have
a lovely vodka called Happy
um and they are crafted to the same sort
of quality standards that we do our
whiskeys so uh we we actually view now
ourselves as a spirit portfolio with an
opportunity to bring Japanese
craftsmanship to the world not just with
whiskey but also with gin some vodkas
Etc
um I apologize I managed to miss those
looking at your website this morning
though I did uh rather appallingly enjoy
looking at lots of Spirits at 8am too
much probably
um touching on on on that in fact where
are people's tastes uh Spirits versus
other drinks like wine and and beers and
others today and not just over the long
term but but in the pandemic where we
did see quite a surge in demand for four
Spirits as people kind of drunk through
the pain of the pandemic yeah I think
the the great thing about the spiritual
industry is one about Innovation uh and
you'll see you know Innovations from us
in Japanese you'll see Innovations in
other areas whether it's ready to drink
whether it's brands with lower alcohol
and it's a it's a fascinating industry
that keeps innovating and that's why I
think Spirits has got a healthy healthy
future because of this mentality of
constantly looking at Innovation and and
satisfying new consumer needs
great stuff well thanks so much for
joining us and uh congrats again on the
uh the the 100 years John
pleasure thank you for having me
[Music]
right time for a look at this morning's
business Pages uh let's have a look at
some of the key stories well the
financial times uh is reporting that uh
w e soda the world's largest natural
soda ash producer plans to float in
London providing a boost to a stock
market that has of course struggled for
new listings uh of late the times has a
story at uh how the digital Bank monzo
faces a hundred million pound loss after
a rapid increase in lending that has
evolved a push into the buy now pay
later industry obviously it's a
significant blow but it's a non-cash
write down for monzo uh the business
page of the telegraph leads with a
rating agency warning that mortgage
rates will tip Britain into recession
this year and a story by Our Guest today
the country's biggest independent TV
producers going up for sale for more
than a billion pounds as its owners deal
with the streaming uh Revolution and uh
Our Guest is Christopher Williams
business editor at the telegraph um
great to see you thanks so much for
joining us why don't we kick off on the
first the first leader article in in
your paper just in terms of uh the view
that the housing market mortgage rates
could push Britain into recession
because we've had this bifurcation of
late where
clearly inflation has persisted and that
that's bad for the prospect for interest
rates but it the only reason interest
rates are also forecast to stay high is
that the outlook for the economy has not
perhaps improved but got less bad so
this article suggests that that's
perhaps a false a false dorm
yeah I mean we're going through cycles
of optimism and pessimism I think around
the economy and I think we're currently
dipping into a bit of a pessimistic
phase you've got Moody's uh in our
papers saying that uh because there are
so many people who need to remortgage
and see you're going to get a lot of
people having their household income
squeezed that comes alongside Catherine
Mann who's on the NPC uh at the bank of
England just uh giving a fairly gloomy
assessment of where they need to go from
here this morning you've seen Larry
Summers the US Economist saying the UK
is going to struggle to avoid recession
um so I just think that uh
the situation we're in where the UK's
inflation seems to be coming more
embedded than a lot of rival economies
um is convincing some people that we're
going to have a slightly tougher time
than um than we thought perhaps two
months ago but obviously these are
economists and um it can change yeah
indeed um Chris I'll touch on on one of
your own articles today that we just
mentioned there so which independent uh
TV producer we are we talking about and
is this a sale because they're a
beneficiary of the streaming Market or
because they're threatened by
this is all three media who are sort of
a conglomeration of a 50 actually uh
Independent Producers they're owned by
Warner Brothers discovery which is one
of the big Hollywood Studios and by
Liberty Global who are actually telecoms
operator and part-time Virgin Media O2
um the sale is is partly driven by
Warner Brothers discovery which is a a a
combination uh that's been executed in
last year very indebted needs to reduce
that debt and doesn't really need to
earn half of a UK producer anymore when
Warner Brothers is one of the world's
biggest producers in its own right
um for Liberty Global which is sort of
that has dabbled in TV
um on the basis that perhaps there was
going to be a sort of convergence of
telecoms and television that hasn't
really happened
um so both of them are kind of looking
around and seeing if they can realize
some of the gains that have been made in
streaming
um over the last decade streaming is
becoming a tougher business
um you know a lot of the Returns on as
high as people had hopes
um so it's just a tougher phase for that
industry all three media has done pretty
well under its Uh current management and
um is likely to be an attractive asset I
think that um it also signals a kind of
return to corporate activity in London
alongside the float of uh of w soda that
you mentioned earlier um you're starting
to see
um a bit some of the gears starting to
turn again in the city after um you know
the banking crisis in the us and our own
sort of uh bond yield problems last year
um shut things down for a while
and Chris let's just touch as well on
the story in the times about about monzo
of course uh one of the the sort of
fintech Darlings of the last five years
or so here there was an explosion in in
the sort of threat that traditional
Banks face both sides of the Atlantic
and across Continental Europe too from
these new fintech players with this
story is it is it the latest example
that perhaps uh whilst the threat's not
going away to traditional banking
players that it might have peaked
I think you would probably struggle to
find traditional Banks you do CDs guys
as much of a threat these days
um the initial threat was around
um user experience and technology and I
think a lot of the traditional banks
have caught up and what you're seeing
here is these smaller Banks going into
riskier forms of uh lending to try and
gain scale which ultimately is the only
way you can make money as a bank is by
being large scale
um and in this case Monto is going to
buy a buy now pay later lending a time
when the consumers being squeezed and
it's it's not especially surprising that
some of that lending is going to go bad
for them
Christopher thanks so much for joining
us much appreciated
now president zielinski has just been
speaking at a European Summit in Moldova
in the last few minutes just moments ago
let's listen
first of all that you really am
um Leo hosted all our people all the
refugees from from the first first days
of full-scale War thing you will never
forget about it
and I think what is very important our
future in EU and
and Ukraine is ready to be in NATO we
are waiting when NATO will be ready to
host and to see and to have Ukraine and
I think security guarantees are very
important not only for Ukraine for our
neighbor's home although because of of
the Russia and of their aggression in
Ukraine and potential aggression for
other parts of Europe
some brief comments there from president
zielinski uh NATO gathering in in
Moldova saying he's ready to be in NATO
where NATO is really important not just
for the likes of Ukraine but for Moldova
the hosts of this Summit also right so
to come here on Ian King live I'll be
speaking to the winners of two
prestigious women in Business Awards
that's next
[Music]
thank you
I'm Becky Johnston a Sky News
correspondent part of the team based
here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
two more and more stabbing and
essentially I think it's more my younger
children there's a team we're not really
surprised by anything these days
so there's reports of a male who can
stand repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here at currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
the river 7 is still rising and people
here in Ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together we aim to be
the best and most trusted place for news
[Music]
thank you
welcome back the co-founder of a food
sharing app has won the prestigious
Verve clico bold woman award Tessa Clark
was praised for her entrepreneurial
skills in helping create the app Oleo
which is now used by more than seven
million people and another big winner in
last night's Awards was Karen Schofield
seal founder of Oceania which harnesses
the benefits of seaweed she was given
the Bold future award which celebrates
her up and coming female leaders of the
future I'm delighted to say that Tess
Clark and Karen Schofield are both with
me now congratulations to you both and
uh thank you as well for for coming in
and and following an awards night
sponsored by Verve clico a very very
impressive quick turnaround
um Tessa I'll start with you so just
just quickly what does Olio do
exist to tackle down was problem of
wasting our homes and local communities
and we do that by connecting people with
our neighbors so they can give away
things that they no longer want or need
rather than waste them or throw them
away and and where are we in in the sort
of progress of that how quickly has it
changed since you launched the app and
how much further is there to go how much
more food is there that's wasted that
could be saved so we've had seven
million people join Olio so far and our
community has collectively shared over
100 million portions of food and also 9
million household items that's had an
incredible environmental impact we've
saved over 16 billion liters of water
for example but we're doing a fraction
of our full potential so we've set
ourselves an enormous goal of a billion
people to be sharing the world's most
precious Resources by 2030. wow amazing
and Karen tell us what what uh oceanium
does yes at Oceania we have developed a
green proprietary technology which
maximizes the value of farm seaweed so
we are looking to catalyze the seaweed
farming industry here in the Western
Hemisphere and by doing so so we produce
products that are in very high demand by
big corporate companies as well as
plant-based ingredients including
food-based food ingredients protein and
fiber nutraceuticals for health and
cosmetics and a ingredient to make
Innovative circular life cycle materials
well and so and so what Drew you to to
seaweed being an opportunity for this in
the first place yes so um I had I had
recently completed a sustainable
Business course at Cambridge and I was
doing a lot of research as to where I
could start a new business that would
have the most impact and I came across a
world Bank report that talked about the
numerous environmental economic and
social benefits of seaweed farming in
food security is going to be hugely
important going forward for food
security it helps mitigate ocean
eutrophication because it absorbs carbon
and nitrogen and importantly creates
jobs along World coastal regions
alternative livelihoods for Fisher
communities
and also it's it's I've always been
involved with issues with women and girl
girls and 70 percent of the aquaculture
Workforce are women so it provides
economic uh freedom and agency for women
around the world wow the direct link
then from from seaweed to to that and
and the awards last night and obviously
uh Tessa these these Awards uh partly
because of these brilliant businesses
you've outlined but but also
specifically uh for your your respective
female leadership talk us through in
your process how important having
mentors in your space has been and and
how you pass that on now so mentors I
think are absolutely critical but even
more important than mentors are role
models and then also money what we women
really really need is money more than
mentors and access to capitalism I think
if you speak to any female Founders the
number one challenge for them when
they're trying to build and scale their
businesses and when we see so many
incredible female Founders who are
tacklings on the world's largest
problems and they are struggling to
access Capital then by shortchanging
women we're really short-changing in
humanity and that's a very big problem
and and uh Karen do you think the whole
process of things like the awards
certainly last night does that make a
difference in itself is it sort of
self-fulfilling or is it just sort of
backward looking no I think it's it's uh
it definitely makes a difference I think
the biblical shining a light on women
business owners and change makers is a
huge benefit for our businesses because
it highlights not only what we're doing
but what the businesses are doing and
the impact that they're having I mean we
wouldn't be here today if it weren't for
the Cleco award so I do think that it is
really important and as Tessa said it
also is important for um for role models
and uh so that that younger women and
other all women can see that there's an
opportunity well Karen Tessa thank you
both very much for joining me today and
uh congrats again on the awards last
night
uh we have time just a quick look uh in
at the markets before we go and uh we
are having a look at the moment to
slight gains here in Europe ftse 100 up
about half a percent uh Continental
Europe but more than that over one
percent that does it for Ian King live
and uh Kimberly Lennon how's you next
actual
[Music]